tan
par
me
[音楽]
背に正央
ああああああっ
ジャガー市沼保
スマーレ2枚はあああ
[音楽]
せ人まなえなココアスレ b 棟デー
tree 始まん出せ3本椅子もここたがやたせてー
ん
カフェ第8
[音楽]
singing dancing そして smiling
私を作るさん元素そんな歌です
らりたい自分を
イメージしよ
というわけ
浜田ぺこ美和子ですよろしくお願いします
皆さん
なりたいイメージってありますか
私たちの仕事はイメージありきなんですね
それがないと
やっていけないと言っても過言ではありません
2008年私はジブリ映画崖の上のポニョの主題歌を振り付け避けていただきました
それが
私にとってすごく大きなステップアップになりました
それまで子供の振り付けなどひとつもしたことなかったんですけれども
あの偉大なる音楽家の久石譲さんに
子供から大人までみんなが全国
楽しめるような唱えながら踊れるようなフリができないかと
まさに私の singing ダンシング歌いながら踊りながら
そして笑顔になるというそういう振りの依頼が来ました
そのとき私は子供のさきほども言いましたように子供の振り付けなどしたことないので
つまりイメージの中で自分が子供になるわけです
例えばポーンやっぽーにょぽーにょこによって何かなって思った時に何か子供は子
触りたくなるとか自分でもそういうのかぽよんとしたものを触りたくなるなぁと思って
それで出来た事が
4にょっポニョっぽんですこれは方や釘をと握るんじゃなくて
をよんぽよんっていう感じですねなんか本当に曖昧でいいですやさしくまあるく
方によっぽ日本のちょっとなんか身体を大きく回したくなりますサッカーなぁまここへ
魚の一例ですあっ多い海か泳いできますね
やっぱ
生きたぽーにょぽーにょぽんにょ膨らんだ
まんまるまマリオ中の女の子という風にできました
これがなんか友達の子供とかを取ってくれたということを聞いた時はとても嬉しかった
です
そして2011年
私は
マルマルモリモリ芦田愛菜ちゃんと鈴木福くんが踊ってくれた
マルマルモリモリを振りつけさせていただきました
この時は2011年で東日本大震災の直後でした
依頼が来たのも本当に本当の直後だったので私の中でそういうイメージすることが
なかなかできませんでした
日本全国そうだったと思うんですけれどもその時にふっと思い出したことが
私がまあそれまでご毎朝ジョギングをしているんですけれども
その時に公園でラジオ体操している方達の姿でした
その方たちの体を動かしている時の映画を
それを当然新鮮な震災の後はやってないんですが
その笑顔を思い出しましたその時にあっ
人ってなんか無理に心を開こうとするんじゃなくて体を動かすことで
なんか元気が出るんじゃないかなと思って
それを持った時に私は公園で遊ぶ子供の頃の自分になりました
私は
泥談合とか作るの大好きだったんですねそこから皆さんもを築ける
マールマールというところが泥だんごを作っている私ですそしてその後
もりもりは砂場で山を小さい山
大きい山を作っていますそこが丸々
モーリー森になります
もし皆さんできる方がいたよってくださいねここから口に近づけてみんなったベイルよ
なとツルツル
ず別途してイメージアップツールツールこそ言いました
ツルツルテカテカほっぺたの横
明日も晴れるかなぁ
という感じです
8ただポニョと違うところは
マルマルモリモリはたい人とを取るところがあります
これはいつまでもう一緒だっようっていうところなんですけどここはちょっとあの
みんなよくねあのせっせとかもう民今の人たちよね
7日開かれないけどてってステップ1と手を合わせることがあります
なんかそうするとなんかみんな心が触れ合えるような気がしてそれをとても思ったのが
その年に
女川の
仮設住宅に生かしていただきました
みんなで丸森を踊ろうというような会だったんですけれども
そこであの皆さんと5まあ手でもっていうところ
皆さんとやってみましたそうすると何か自然に笑顔が溢れて
なんか私もとても心が通じ合えたようでうれしかったです
[音楽]
ではここで
私の子供の頃に遡りたいと思います
この私のぺ子という名前はうちの家しがつけました
赤ちゃんの時に舌を出す癖があるところから不二家のペコみたいだといってこと
命名されてしまいました
うちの父親は
阪神タイガースのもっと選手監督
松木謙治郎と言います
皆さんの野球はを好きかどうかですけれども
プロ野球創設時の選手なので皆さんも知らないと思いますし私も現役時代は全く知り
ません
でもあの住んでいたのが関西だったのでそこがさすが阪神タイガースで私たちはいつも
注目の的というか赤注目されていました
なので何か下手の発言や
行動とかが父に迷惑かかると気を使った母にいつも言われていたので何か私はちょっと
臆病な子供になっていたような気がします
でもそんな父と母が芸術音楽とか好きだったので私を3歳の時にバレーとピアノそして
バレエ団ではタップダンスもやってました
それを鳴らしてくれました
これが3歳の初舞台です
えっと
本当に
先ほどの言ったようにちょっと人見知りだったし何か発言やすることをとても臆病に
思っていた私ですけれども
バレエの発表会やピアノの発表会
なんかこうやって人前でやることがあるときすごくワクワク楽しくなったんです
なので
一生懸命練習しましたし
日曜日は一日中バレエ団に入って自分たちのレッスンもそうですけど
先輩の作品そういうのもう覗き見して動くいつもいつも
ばレーダーの生活が楽しかったんですでも小学校5年の時にうちの父が今度東映
フライヤーズ
今の日ハムの監督に就任して東京に健康することになりました
その時私はもう
離れたくなくて
バレエの先生に相談したら家に残っていいよと家から学校も行けばいい
バレーもヤバイって言われたんですけど
家にそれを言うとも大激怒されましたもちろんです
でそこでまぁ泣く泣く東京に転校してきました
そうすると今度私は母さんにいたころを関西弁を喋っている意識がまったくなかったん
ですけど
東京に来てみるとじつは
関西弁だったんですねまぁあっはい
あのクラスの生徒たちに私が国王の教科書読むと笑われるし
そしてちょっと呼び出されて1から10まで言ってみろ九大て
12345678空中富永取ってもらう理由ですねそのうち私もちょっともう
六太してきまして思い余ってその首謀者に
ねほんとにやめてくださいときっぱり言いました
そうすると
なぜかそこから心が解けてまああのみんなも誰だから飼っていただけだと思うんです
けどそこからなんか
class 10仲良くなって6年生になる前には本当に皆で打ち解けてました
私はその
かあさん入ったときにやっぱりちょっと引っ込み思案だったしあの給食とかも全然食べ
ないようなちょっと変な子供だったんですけど
東京に来てなんかみんなと馴染んできて自分の心も開いてきたら
給食も少し食べられるようになってきましたそのくらい心が開いた瞬間でした
中学ぐらいになると
もう本当にギターを弾いて学園祭で歌うということが大好きになりました
そこからクラブ活動はダンス部ダンス部で創作ダンスをやることで今の振付師の始まり
があったのかもしれません
もうそれからは歌って踊ってのプロになりたくてなりたくて
そしてなんかそういう当てはないかなと思ったんです
そうすると
ある時父のスポーツ新聞4読んでいたら
なんかがパッと目に飛び込んで光るものが飛び込んでこんなちっちゃい記事だったん
ですけどそれがシンガーソングライターコンテスト
出場者募集ということだったんですね
早速応募しましたで
まぁそこに会場に入ったら歌ったものを録音して審査されるんですけど
あのーもう感と甲信越地区だけで1000組ぐらいの応募があるので
宝くじに当たったようなもんだと思ってくれと言われました
あそっかと思ったんですけど
それがなんと予選も突破
ちゃんと甲信越地区も突破そして全国大会に駒を進めたのでるん
そして
その
久松大会に行ってみるとですね実はこんな小さい記事だと思わないぐらいな大きな大会
で
場所は日比谷の野外音楽堂として審査員にはすごい超一流な方に混じってゲストでます
とあゆみさんがいらっしゃいました
私はその頃クイーンが大好きだったので
クイーンのフィンランドアクトリーに憧れてか曲のような曲を歌えました
そこで
当時公明なぁ異例というちょっとあの閉じた女の子の歌なんですね
あんな子がちょっと途中で昔を思い出して明るくなるんですけど結局また最後は
閉じこもっちゃうようなそんな暗い歌を歌ったら
まあ審査員からある意味を受けになりまして
見事グランプリを頂きました
そこからです
表彰式終わって楽屋に戻ったらユーミンがはパパっと近づいてきてくれて
お嬢ちゃん歌うまいねくりくりくりって頭を撫でハました
そして私のプロになる
きっかけとなったんです
事務所はユーミンといっしょそしてシングルを出し
アルバムの制作に入っているところで
実はユーミンが独立して事務所がなくなってしまいました
まあそういうこともあるんですねと思ってでもそこから
ある日バイト生活をしている時に
電話かかってきて表コンサートを見に行きなさいとそして学園絶対来てと
で私がそのコンサートに行くと
もうそれはそれは素晴らしい世界デー
私がここを求めていたものを歌って踊って笑顔になるはここにあるんだと思っ
そして終わって楽屋に行くとそれはユーミンのコンサートです
見たでしょ次から手伝ってもらうからねと言って次のツアーから
コーラスとして参加させていただきました
そこから私のプロフェッショナルな生活がスタートしたわけです
そして
いろんな人のステージに立つことができました
大江千里山中部
原田知世さん今井美樹さん
鈴木雅之さん安全地帯そして浜崎あゆみさんです
そんないろんなステージにコーラスとしてまで参加していたら何かもっとみんなが輝く
ことが私に考えられるんじゃないかと思ってそして振り付けの仕事をやるようになり
ました
そして振り付けをやって言うと今度は何かステージ全体のフォーメーションを考え
られるんじゃないかとそういうことでステージングという仕事をやりました
そしてそうやっているとすべてを色づけしたいということで人の仕事もすることになり
ました
にそうやっていろんな仕事をこなしてきたんですけれども
まあいろんな夢は広がりました
そして
今年は大風呂真希さんのツアーにコーラスとして参加した振り付けもやらせていただき
ましたけど参加したり
そして歌仲間9人でコーラス9という作品もやらせていただきました
女優業もちょっと凍らせないというミュージカルですね
女優業もちょっとスタートです
私は
人と一緒のことが同じようなことをするのが嫌でした
そして
ファッションも人と違うものが来たかった
パフォーマンスは自分にしかできないことをやりたかった
音楽も自分をもっと掘り下げたかった
でもなんかその偉大な父のことがあってそこを超えられね自分が言いました
でもなんかそれがやっと
今秒8イメージを広げてきたことで10日たちと近くなっているような気がします
始める時が始め時です
空のように広い心の人間になりたいっ
海のようにたおやかな存在でありたい
風のようにしなやかに流れるように行きたい
イメージは
無限です
どんなことも
イメージするとどんな人にもなれるどんなところにも飛んでいける
そして
イメージをたくさん持つことは自分の可能性を拓く鍵だと思っています
みんな
この中に
この中に自分の中に宇宙あります
みんなでいきましょう自分の中の宇宙旅行
なりたい自分をイメージしをやってみますか
なりたい顔の横になりたい自分を
いメジャー広げていく頭の中
4を
ん
はいどうもありがとうございました浜田ぺこ美代子でしたありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]
par
ああああああ
[音楽]